so let's start with kind of kovat 19 or
coronavirus I think everyone at this
point has heard about it most people are
being quarantined or staying at home and
stay away from people with you social
distancing gave us kind of just a one
minute like what exactly is this and why
is it different than all of the other
kind of seasonal things that we would
see that that are somewhat related so I
think from a high level one of the big
differences from coronavirus is it's
actually is this mortality rate that was
the big controversy back you know three
or four weeks ago month ago at first
there was this is only this day in China
because it's not very it's it's why
would it spread to anywhere else and so
what you have to look at is the are not
so that means for each person that's
infected how many people will that one
person infect and if it's more than one
and that means this has the potential to
turn into an epidemic or pandemic is now
more people are being infected and
recovery
Crona is did that's what first caught my
attention in which was makes it not
different from the seasonal flu like
that can have an are not above one but
then that combined with this mounting
evidence especially with that ER doctor
that was kind of the whistleblower on
this when he died that really got my
attention you can't you know that death
was as prominent he was a young
supposedly healthy ER doc so this was
more fatal than the seasonal flu you
rarely see people from the seasonal flu
that are young die may be sick and then
elderly people sure so the are not is
one thing and to compare this to other
historical because I know which I got a
lot of flack for this early on in
Twitter when I kind of started talking
about the motorized in early February
they were like just talk about Bitcoin
don't talk about this though what do you
know about that and one of the things to
look I'm saying is how is this different
from the flu this is no different from
the flu and it was that or or I was
actually so adored for the flu but the
second thing of someone is it is people
felt like they were being tricked again
by the media in the sense that SARS was
supposed to be this big outbreak that
didn't really seem to amount to much
Ebola but the the difference is with
SARS which is why it realized early on
this wasn't playing out that
way as SARS was not very contagious
before you started having symptoms so it
was much easier to this is longer than a
minute but I was much easier to contain
because once you get sick you you stayed
home and then you didn't really affect
anyone else the big difference with cope
in nineteen now what coronavirus is that
you can be contagious while you
asymptomatic so you don't know and
you're spreading it and then you get
sick a few days later but you already
infected two three or four people so I'd
say that's why this is different than
say Ebola or SARS and then it also
commands up more fatal element than the
seasonal flu our bodies are not used to
this virus essentially